NASA has observed a nearby supermassive black
hole “burping,” which has lead to new
insights.
Namely, that black holes make terrible dinner
guests.
Hello earthlings, Julian here for DNews.
On January 5th, 2016 NASA announced that its
Chandra X-ray Observatory has discovered something
quite peculiar.
26 million light years away, or what astronomers
call “nearby,” the supermassive black
hole anchoring the galaxy NGC 5195 has spewed
out two huge bursts of energy.
Lead author of the study Eric Schlegel of
the University of Texas said that if black
holes can be described as eating nearby stars
and gas, then this is analogous to a burp.
NGC 5195 is colliding with a much larger galaxy
called NGC 5194, better known as the Whirlpool
galaxy, because, well, look at it.
It’s possible the x-ray arcs were caused
when matter was gravitationally catapulted
as the galaxies collided, but Schlegel rejects
this idea.
Instead astronomers think this 'burping' black
hole gorged itself on the Whirlpool galaxy's
dust, and the infalling matter had so much
energy it caused waves of X-Rays to "burp"
out into space.
Now, I know what you’re thinking.
If there’s one thing everybody knows about
black holes, it’s that nothing gets out.
If there’s one thing that smart alecs know
about black holes it’s that only Hawking
radiation gets out.
So was the black hole somehow giving something
back?
Not really.
What's happening here is the matter outside
the Schwarzschild radius -- or the point of
no return -- is heating up from the galaxies
colliding which is causing this blasting off
of x-rays.
In fact some of the brightest objects in the
universe are the areas surrounding supermassive
black holes called quasars.
The bursts from NGC 5195 are different though
because they’re two distinct waves that
were shot off 3 million and 6 million years
ago.
Interestingly, optical telescopes found these
waves of X-rays have formed thin lines of
hydrogen gas at their leading edges, like
a snow plow or broom.
It’s this line of gas and dust that definitively
shows the x-rays are traveling away from the
black hole, not falling into it.
Some areas have pockets of HII, a hydrogen
ion… commonly seen as a sign that new stars
are forming, so it’s possible this belching
process answers a longstanding question.
Often the area around supermassive black holes
are lacking in star formation, so it’s possible
that this belch is a rarely glimpsed intermediate
stage where stars are forming but being pushed
away from the center of the galaxy.
Schlegel says this may have been more common
in the early universe when galaxies were more
densely packed, but today it’s harder to
see examples of black hole feedback shaping
star formation.
This "burping" black hole is close enough
to be observed clearly by Chandra, which took
11 looks at it between 2000 and 2012 to gather
this data.
So these findings represent the work of 15
years, and the exact process for how this
release of energy happened is still unknown.
Schlegel himself says more research is needed.
Black holes are one of the all-time coolest
astronomical topics, and it’s fun to think
about what would happen if you fell into one.
Did I say fun?
I meant horrifying.
Anyway one of my first videos for DNews was
about just that and you can see it here.
Do you feel like there are some stellar topics
(pun intended) we’re neglecting?
Let us know in the comments, or on facebook
or twitter with the hashtag #AskDNews.
Subscribe for more, and I’ll see you next
time on DNews.